der schönste tag im leben soll sie sein
die hochzeit die verbindung zweier
menschen vor dem gesetz und für einige
auch vor gott
doch so schön die liebe auch beginn sie
muss nicht unbedingt schön enden
knapp 40 prozent aller ehen werden der
schweiz geschieden
warum heiraten dennoch so viele und wie
lässt sich der bund fürs leben mit würde
beenden wenn es schiefgeht
darüber spreche ich heute mit helene
klar die rechtsanwältin vertritt hat
mehr als 40 jahren scheidungswillige vor
gericht und findet heiraten noch immer
eine gute idee
herzlich willkommen frau klar guten tag
frau klar sie gelten als gefürchtete
scheidungsanwältin österreichs passt
ihnen diese zuschreibung sehr amüsiert
mich ich bin nicht wirklich
furchterregend und ich denke wenn man
als frau so bezeichnet wird dann
bedeutet das offenbar dass man von einer
frau doch nicht erwartet dass sie sich
für ihre klienten auf die füße stellt
und versucht das bestmögliche für die zu
erreichen und vielleicht kann ich dazu
sagen dass ich ja eher ein ruhiger
mensch bin eine leise stimme habe also
das bonner volle auftreten vor gericht
ist nicht meins aber ich habe halt eine
gewisse beharrlichkeit und mit der habe
ich möglicherweise x die gegner
überrascht weil sie sich gedacht haben
sie blasen mich weg und das ist dann
doch nicht so leicht gegangen und
dadurch habe ich dann diesen ruf
erworben als furchterregend sie machen
das ja auch tatsächlich schon seit 40
jahren und sie sind sehr erfolgreich
dabei haben sie diesen beruf ja nicht
wirklich gesucht sondern sie waren
mitglied der spd in österreich und sie
waren in der frauenbüro
frauenrechtsbewegung aktiv waren eine
emanzipierte frauen einstimmt
ich habe mich natürlich dafür
interessiert und wie ich jung war
also ich bin 48 geboren ich war mir 68
da war es ziemlich schwer aufgeschlossen
zu sein und nichts von der
studentenbewegung mitzukriegen und
natürlich ich habe schon meine
studienzeit also meine schulzeit vor
allem mit den mitschülerinnen wo
eigentlich die väter alle
kriegsteilnehmer waren und den
lehrerinnen die mindestens beim bdm
waren wenn ich schlimmeres habe ich
schon als ein bisschen miefig und
belastend empfunden habt mir dann schon
als studentin erwartet dass ich bei den
sozialistischen studenten den anschluss
an die freiheit finde ist dann leider
nur zum teil gelungen weil die
sozialistischen studenten waren damals
äußerst revolution her und mit zu
kleinigkeiten die mich interessiert
hätten
haben sie sich nicht abgegeben sondern
habe mir gedacht dann die weltrevolution
welche kleinigkeiten sie denn
interessiert andere studienbedingungen
und vor allem wann sie engagiert gegen
den vietnamkrieg und da konnte wiederum
ich nicht mit weil dadurch dass mein
vater in amerika in der emigration war
und von 40 bis 47 in amerika gelebt hat
wenn ich natürlich aufgewachsen mit
einer sehr pro amerikanischen haltung
und an demonstrationen wo man
amerikanische flaggen verbrannt hat
konnte ich einfach nicht teilnehmen
konnten sie nicht einerseits enttäuscht
gewesen wäre oder das haben sie nicht
übers herz gebracht ich habe selbst
gewusst dass wir unsere existenz dem
umstand verdanken dass mein vater in
amerika zuflucht gefunden hat also ich
würde aufstehen wenn die amerikanische
runde gespielt wird und ich würde sicher
nicht zuschauen wie eine amerikanische
fahne verbrannt wird das wäre absurd
nicht für an meiner herkunftsgeschichte
er das geht auch noch erhärten
jetzt wenn keine fahnen mehr verbrannt
und jetzt ist die jetzt fordert mich
niemand mehr auch von demonstrationen
teilzunehmen
aber ich glaube auch dass das gilt bis
heute doch ja wenn sie gerade die
geschichte ansprechen das ist ja
tatsächlich für sie glaube ich auch für
ihre biografie sehr bedeutet haben dass
ihr vater ja schon anwalt waren ja jeder
dass er als jüdischer anwalt zufolge 2,4
38 und die mir 39 ist es ihm gelungen
nach england zu entkommen und eben dann
von england in die usa
und dann kam er zurück als das
österreichische justizministerium dann
auch gesagt hat nach dem krieg man hätte
gerne die anwälte tja jetzt ein
sogenannter parteilose justizminister
der hatte den anstand die emigrierten
jüdischen rechtsanwälte einzuladen dass
sie zurückkommen
und davon hat mein vater gebrauch
gemacht und ist also im jahr 47 nach
österreich zurückgekommenen haben meine
eltern sofort geheiratet und im jahr 48
bin ich zur welt gekommen also dann ging
es sozusagen schlag auf schlag und
wollten sie denn auch jura studieren war
für sie ihr vater ein leuchtendes
vorbildung die nachdem das gleiche
machen mein vater war für mich ein
leuchtendes vorbild dabei jus studieren
wollte ich trotzdem nicht das waren wir
zu fahren und zu trocken und ich habe da
immer eine große
liebe zu literatur zum theater und allen
derartigen schönen dingen und das war
für meinen vater bei no go dass ich
irgendetwas studiere womit nicht
sichergestellt ist dass ich mich
erhalten kann wenn mein vater war bei
meiner geburt 44 das ist heutzutage
denken da viele männer erstmals darüber
nach ob sie kinder haben wollen aber
mein vater hat das immer als schrecke
ich empfunden dass er so relativ alt ist
im verhältnis zu mir und seine sorge war
immer dass er mich unversorgt
zurückgesetzt und daher wollte er dass
ich etwas praktisches studiere und seine
idee wäre gewesen pharmazie
ich habe nur leider überhaupt kein
interesse oder wie soll interesse
natürlich für naturwissenschaften aber
es ist eindeutig nicht meine begabung
gewesen die war immer mehr im sprachlich
geisteswissenschaftlichen bereich
und nachdem wir uns seiten nicht einigen
konnten
was ich studieren soll habe ich dann
halt doch losgemacht das ist eine
redewendung in wien studiert oder mach
studios
ich hab halt hughes gemacht aber ich
muss sagen
rückblickend bin ich auch mit meiner
berufswahl sehr zufrieden
na ja auf jeden fall sie war sehr
erfolgreich hat er bestimmt nicht und
wenn ihr noch einmal zurück gehen jetzt
zur frauenbewegung leider ist das ja so
ein gefühl jahre und sie gesagt haben ja
so ganz stimmt das nicht aber sie
erzählen doch in vielen interviews mit
ihnen dass die genossinnen ihnen dann ja
eingeschickt haben scheidungswillige
waren
ich war natürlich dann schon
ich war immer ein politischer mensch ist
war ja auch meine herkunftsfamilie mein
vater war ja auch schon ein sehr
berührender sozialdemokrat und natürlich
war ich da geprägt und hat auch meinen
vorstellungen von einem gerechten leben
entsprochen aber sie haben sich als
juristin daneben eingesetzt als anwältin
und wurden gebete sind von der damaligen
frauenministerin 1982 eine broschüre zu
verfassen
mittlerweile gibt es von ihnen
entscheidungs ratgeber für frauen gibt
es bereits in dritter auflage ja frau
klar wenn wir vielleicht jetzt sind die
in die gegenwart werden
wieso entscheidungs ratgeber für frauen
heute das klingt ja so ein bisschen so
als wäre entscheidungs ratgeber für
männer was anderes ja obwohl man es
natürlich reziprok lesen kann und ich
auch zu der ersten broschüre von der
donau immer gern erzählt dass johanna
dohnal mein manuskript hat gegengelesen
lassen von ihrem chauffeur der musste ja
immer lang auf sie warten wenn sie
irgendwo war
und der hat das immer gelesen um
einerseits zu bestätigen dass es
verständlich ist und andererseits nicht
gehässig gegen männer
also das muss man natürlich bei so etwas
immer beachten
und genauso wo stehe ich zu dem
scheidungsrate geber für frauen dem
kommerziellen von einem verlag
herausgegebenen dass es keine anti
männliche kampfschrift ist sondern
wirklich eine sachliche information über
die rechtslage hinweis auf probleme die
bei scheidungen entstehen und wie man
sie am besten löst und sie sagen ja aber
schon frauen haben noch spezifische
schwierigkeiten immer noch nach wie vor
unter der scheidung sie sagen auch in
gewissen texten von ihnen frauen leiden
öfter als männer unter romantischer
verblödung was ist romantische verblüht
ja das frauen vielleicht doch etwas mehr
als männer ich meine es gibt immer
auch männer die ähnliche
verhaltensweisen zeigen aber doch
deutlich weniger als dass frauen sehr
gutgläubig sind beim heiraten und sich
eigentlich nicht vorstellen können oder
wollen dass sich das verhältnis zum an
einmal ändert und daher sehr viel voraus
leistungen erbringen
in erwartung einer lebenslänglichen
guten ehe und der bietet ihnen aber
nachher das gesetz sehr wenig hilfe wenn
sich diese erwartungen nicht erfüllen
aber warum denken sie frauen hätten mehr
von dieser verblödung um es böse zu
sagen ich mein man könnte ja sagen
gerade sie aus familien müssten doch
eigentlich nicht paternalistisch auf die
frauen blicken sondern davon ausgehen
dass frauen heute genauso selbstbewusst
darüber nachdenken können worin willige
ich eigentlich ein frauen sind ja nicht
einfach opfer frau und sie nicht opfer
bei frauen sind doch eher diejenigen die
die kinder kriegen beitrag des vaters
zum kinderkriegen diese ein relativ
bescheidener und den rest muss jedoch
die frau erledigen und daher ergibt sich
aus dieser rolle der frau sofern sie
mutter wird gibt sich natürlich eine
gewisse einschränkung ihrer sonstigen
lebenschancen in dieser phase und da
führt es dann halt einfach dazu dass die
frau will sich schon zu hause ist dann
auch gleich alle anderen alten
rollenmuster übernimmt also wenn schon
der mann jetzt alleinverdiener ist weil
die frau in karenz ist dann ist doch
klar dass sie die ganze haushaltsarbeit
macht und das natürlich nur sie nachts
aufsteht wenn das kind schreit weil er
seinen schlaf braucht weil er am
nächsten tag wieder arbeiten gehen muss
das ergibt sich alles so scheinbar
zwangsläufig
und es hat sich aber in der zwischenzeit
auch glaube ich im bearish feststellen
lassen dass dieses rollenmuster dann
wenn es einmal so gekippt ist nie wieder
geändert wird innerhalb einer beziehung
ja also das heißt auch wenn die
kleinkind phase vorbei ist noch immer
die frau die jene die gegen die kocht
wäscht und bügelt und wenn sie arbeiten
geht dann muss halt ihre berufstätigkeit
sich den familiären verpflichtungen
unterordnen
aber sie machen diese arbeit jetzt seit
40 jahren haben sie nicht das gefühl
dass sich die rollenverständnis doch
irgendwie zu gunsten von gleichstellung
verbessert haben oder sind sie da
pessimistisch ganz im gegenteil aus war
das hat sich enorm verschlechtert in den
letzten jahren also waren die frauen vor
40 jahren wesentlich emanzipierter
teilweise und außerdem war es auch
damals leichter muss man objektiv sagen
nichts
vor 40 jahren hatten wir noch
vollbeschäftigung oder 45 jahren wie der
anwalt geworden bin haben wir noch
vollbeschäftigung und eine frau die gar
nicht gearbeitet hat hat ihren
ehemaligen chef angerufen und gefragt ob
sie wiederkommen soll und eine frau die
halbtags gearbeitet hat hat den chef
gefragt ob sie ganztags arbeiten soll
und das schiff hat jedes mal freudig ja
gesagt und jetzt arbeiten hoch
qualifizierte frauen teilzeit
wenn ich frage ob sie statt 24 stunden
nicht vielleicht wenigstens mal 30
stunden arbeiten könnten damit ihr
einkommen und auch ihre spätere pension
dadurch ein bisschen besser werden
sagen sie jetzt nicht aber in zwei
jahren geht vielleicht eine kollegin in
pension vielleicht an
also es hat sich am arbeitsmarkt enormes
verändert und was man auch nicht
ausblenden darf es sind die
wohnungskosten explodiert also in den
siebziger und achtziger jahren gab es
zumindest in wien
noch einen großen bestand an
altbauwohnungen natürlich mit den
erstklassigen zustand aber zu relativ
geringen mieten und herrichten konnte
man sich ja dann so eine bruchbude
selber nach maßgabe der mittel
jetzt hat man überall fabelhaft
entkernte und revitalisierte und ich
weiß nichts groß wohnungen zu preisen
die sich kein mensch leisten kann und
das macht dann die situation der frauen
und wahnsinnig schwierig ist ja
wahnsinnig schwer sie also dass eine
frau sich scheiden lässt weil der mann
sich nicht im haushalt beteiligt wodurch
sich mit geringschätzung behandelt oder
was ich da vor 40 jahren hatte wo es mir
manchmal ein bisschen übertrieben
vorgekommen ist meine frau mir mal
gesagt mein mann hat für sich und die
kinder frische badetücher ins badezimmer
gebracht und für mich nicht und daraus
habe ich erkannt dass ich für ihn
eigentlich nicht existiere und warum
soll ich mit dem weiter zusammen leben
also das kam mir schon vor 40 jahren
überkandidelt vor deswegen habe ich mir
wahrscheinlich gemerkt aber auf die idee
habe ich werde heutzutage eine frau
überhaupt nicht mehr kommen das ist
jenseits jenseits des möglichen dass man
wegen so was eine ehe hin schmerzt die
frage ist ja auch wir denken wir
überhaupt über die ehe nach und auch
über die liebe nach und ich habe hier
diese kugeln mitgebracht die beiden
ineinander verhakten miteinander so
kugel verschmolzenen menschen sie
lächeln das ist natürlich ein sozusagen
sinnbildlich für den mythos der kugel
menschen auch ist der diese geschichte
erzählt in der version von platon und
erzählt wie die menschen als kugeln
durch die welt gerollt sind ja und
aufmüpfig wurden und der gott zeus die
kugeln gespalten hat und seither suchen
wir unsere bessere hälfte ganz
verzweifelt
das könnte ja ein modell der ehe seien
wir suchen die bessere hälfte
das romantische ideal demgegenüber gibt
es auch das ökonomische modell der
das sagt na ja eine idee das ist eine
zweckgemeinschaft da gibt es eine frau
die brauchten in erster linie
finanzielle sicherheit ein mann der
braucht in erster linie nachkommen um
die tun sich zusammen lange zeit hat er
das ökonomische modell gegolten
dann kam das romantische modell welches
modell ist das richtige frau klar
also ja ich denke mir es gefällt mir
nicht zu sagen der mann braucht
nachkommen und die frau braucht
ökonomische sicherheit weil eigentlich
kann sich natürlich die frau ökonomische
sicherheit ganz gut selbst verschaffen
und die frau hat auch interesse an
nachkommen also ich sehe hier in der
verschmelzung der beiden menschen so
schön dass er sich ansieht dass oder
wird man ja ganz sentimental wenn man
sich diese ineinander verschmolzen
liebenden am sieht aber ich würde mal
davon ausgehen dass die interessen
völlig gleich gelagert sind beide
brauchen beides jeder will ökonomische
sicherheit und jeder sollte eigentlich
seinen wunsch nach nachkommen nachkommen
können
und was mich eben immer beschäftigt als
gerechtigkeitsfrage ist warum die
erfüllung des wunsches nach nachkommende
man so leicht gemacht wird und der frau
so schwer
obwohl durch die frau diejenige ist die
die nachkommen in die welt setzt wird
sie irgendwie für diese fähigkeit
bestraft und das denke ich mehr hängt
damit zusammen dass wird auch eine
patriarchalische gesellschaft haben wo
man es eigentlich den frau leidet dass
sie diejenigen sind die die kinder in
die welt setzen und alle darauf aus sind
sie dafür zu bestrafen für diese
fähigkeiten sehen sie diese straße
lesen sie mal unsere zeitung an
also ich bin immer fasziniert wenn ich
den wirtschaftsteil lese wenn ihnen
irgendein manager vorgestellt wird
der wahnsinnig wichtig ist und dann
steht immer er sei ein toller vater von
vier kindern
und meistens hat er die vier kinder
nicht mit einer frau sondern mit
mehreren nacheinander
und wann ist er ein toller vater wenn
der 70 stunden in der woche arbeitet wie
man dann zuvor gelesen hat also offenbar
genügt es dass man als vater am abend
nach hause kommt den kindern den kopf
stellt und sagt geht schon schlafen und
schon ist man ein guter vater und bei
der frau die es momentan die tendenz der
zuschreibung also frauen mit kindern
machen momentan eigentlich alles falsch
nicht sie brauchen vielleicht in der
schwangerschaft und sie stillen zu lange
oder sie spielen gar nicht dass beides
böse sie bleiben zu lang zu hause oder
zu kurz zu hause
sie können sich nicht von den kindern
lösen oder sie vernachlässigen sie und
jedenfalls haben sie in ihrer
beruflichen karriere nachteile
und wenn sie arbeiten und sich um die
kinder kümmern
dann fühlt sich garantiert der man
vernachlässigt und sucht sich eine
andere und da sitzen dann junge
richterinnen bei gericht und nicken
eifrig mit den köpfen
wenn dann der mann schildert wie er
vernachlässigt wurde weil sich die
frauen haben mehr um die kinder
gekümmert hat und nicht mehr um ihn und
abends zu müde war für sex und die frau
geschieden und hat alle wirtschaftlichen
nachteile dessen und mittlerweile aber
auch nicht mehr sagen wir als
kompensation eine ungestörte beziehung
mit ihren kindern sondern da kommen ja
dann die väter die sich bisher nicht um
die kinder gekümmert haben schnell drauf
dass es günstig ist wenn sie nach der
scheidung die kinder viel über sich
haben will dann zahlen sie weniger
unterhalt und genau finden es dann die
gleichen jungen richterinnen normal dass
das kind am 5
16 12 mal da mal dort sein soll
und wir haben die traurigen mütter die
am 24 12
allein zu hause hocken weil das kind
oder die kinder sind beim siegreichen
vater seiner neuen geliebten also das
bessere verwischung der horizont zu sein
interessant ist ja ich stimme ihnen
völlig zu sgs und teil dieses so
genannten parkplatz es gibt im moment
zum beispiel den herr stark trat wife
also von traditionen wife traditionelle
frauen oder frauen bilder abgekürzt
unter diesem herrscht posten frauen nur
rund um die welt oder aus den
industrieländern ja wie sie wieder das
traditionelle rollenbild bevorzugen wie
sie tagsüber kuchen backen und den mann
mit schürze bekleidet empfangen wir
schon parat und den kuchen schauen zu
den kindern und so weiter gibt ihnen
warum sinkt aber dann gleich habe ich
auch in der schweiz noch recherchiert
wie im moment die gesetzliche lage ist
und mit allen mit denen ich gesprochen
haben haben gesagt im grunde genommen
ist die gesetzesgrundlage in der schweiz
eigentlich relativ fortschrittlich auch
das scheidung leicht ja hat man viel wir
erreicht haben und umgekehrt ich habe zb
auch markus theunert gefragt von männer
ch ist eine menge organisation und er
hat gesagt tatsächlich die
rechtsprechung ist eigentlich sehr
gleichgestellt für mann und frau
allerdings kommt es oft dann wenn es um
die frage der kinder geht wird es wenn
es streit gibt schnell den zweifeln der
frau auch rechnung getragen und männer
müssen auch aufpassen dass man ihnen
nicht plötzlich die kinder die obhut für
die kinder entzieht weil der verdacht im
raum steht dass sie irgendwie mit den
kindern nicht richtig umgehen also
zuweilen haben auch die männer einen
nachteil ja das behaupten sie vor allem
männer fühlen sich immer benachteiligt
sind aber nicht sehen sind die
rechtslage dass es in österreich auch so
das ist eben seit der
familienrechtsreform so wir haben eine
erstklassige rechtslage die männer und
frauen völlig gleich behandelt
aber da zeigt sich eben das recht und
gesetz das ist ein überbau phänomen
und das nützt uns nichts wenn frauen
formell gleiche rechte haben wenn sie
gesellschaftlich nicht gleich berechtigt
sind oder wenn ihre gesellschaftliche
besonderheit nicht berücksichtigt wird
und natürlich finde ich diese
traditionellen frauen die lieber
kuchenbacken finde ich natürlich
furchtbar das sind über angepassten die
sich sind zeitströmungen anpassen wollen
ist nutzt ihnen eh nix wenn sie mal 50
sind und schon vielen kuchen essen aus
dem leim gegangen
sucht sich der mann er eine jüngere also
warum sie so pessimistisch warum glauben
sie nicht an die google warum sollten
sie nicht man kann gar nicht
pessimistisch ich bin geprägt von
erfahrungen und natürlich kenne ich habe
auch ganz viele frauen die dieses
traditionelle rollenbild nicht wollen
und die gerne ihren beruf ausüben würden
aber die es eben nicht können weil und
das ist in wirklichkeit das ungelöste
problem diese betreuungsarbeit die für
kinder
das ist ja kein frosch der weg köpft das
ist ja eine arbeit die gemacht werden
muss kinder können eben nicht von selber
wachsen nicht auf bäumen können sich
nicht selbst versorgen
für die muss gesorgt werden und nun bin
ich sehr dafür dass es gute
kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen gibt also
in österreich am land haben wir noch
viele kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen jung
12 uhr mittags zu sperren da es jede
berufstätigkeit der mutter unmöglich
aber dass man jetzt die
kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen als
allheilmittel nimmt und sagt wir
brauchen längere öffnungszeiten und
alles wird gut das stimmt ja nicht kein
kind will bis 8 am abend
im kindergarten oder in der schule seien
aber die arbeitszeiten sind so dass
frauen im handel nicht nicht
rechtsanwältinnen die eine hohe
befriedigung aus ihrer tätigkeit haben
und auch gut verdienen sondern
handelsangestellte die an der wursttheke
wurst aufschneiden müssen bis acht
arbeiten wann sollen die sich um ihre
kinder kümmern also in wirklichkeit
haben wir eine entwicklung gaga so in
der arbeitswelt und in der arbeitszeit
die es zunehmend den frauen immer
schwerer macht
beruf und familie zu verbinden aber das
wäre als eigentliche ziel der arbeitstag
kommen wir zurück zur ehe interessant
ist ja dass sie die eigentlich von den
scheidungen leben kann man so sagen sind
eine person die scheidungen eigentlich
nicht empfiehlt sie sagen
wortwörtlich besser eine ehe ohne liebe
als eine scheidung ohne geld ja das ist
natürlich eine überspitzte formulierung
aber sagen wir mal ich betrachte die
scheidung als die blinddarm-operation
die man nicht mutwillig macht solange
chameleon tust wickel auch noch helfen
würden also eine scheidung bedeutet hat
einfach dass man auch nachher das
vermögen teilen muss und die scheidung
de an sich ist ja eine ökonomische
angelegenheit nicht das tun zwei
menschen ihre arbeitskraft und ihr
einkommen zusammen unterhalten damit
eine wohnung genau das reicht er
vielleicht das ist doch ein ökonomisches
modell vielleicht auch ein wochenendhaus
in ein auto und es geht ihnen dadurch
relativ gut und wenn man das auseinander
schneidet haben beide nachher weniger
und daher sollte man sich das gut
überlegen ob das wirklich der notwendige
schritt ist und ob man nicht anderes tun
kann um das zusammenleben besser zu
gestalten
aber frau klar ich werde gerne eine
andere person noch noch einfügen thomas
maier thomas mayer ist bekannt geworden
vor allem mit seinem buch über
wolkenbruch
wolkenbruchs tanz in die arme einer
schicksal glaub ich heißt das buch wurde
auch verfilmt und er hat ein buch
geschrieben trend aber ich ein trennungs
ratgeber im grunde genommen und thomas
meier sagt eigentlich das gegenteil er
sagt lieber arm und allein als reich um
nicht passend verbunden
ich glaube der war noch nie arm das also
kennen das buch nicht aber es ist sicher
so dass wenn man unter dem zusammenleben
mit einem gar nicht passenden partner
so leidet das man psychosomatisch krank
wird dann ist es sicher besser man
trennt sich aber eigentlich ist das ja
selten weil eben meistens heiraten wir
die leute aus eigenem antrieb dass ein
junges mädchen einen mann heiratet ihn
ihr die eltern vorgeführt haben kommt
ihr heutzutage bei uns doch eher selten
vor
also irgendwas hat sehr offenbaren ihm
gefunden und er an ihr auch also
irgendwann waren sicher die beiden
zumindest sympathisch hätten sie an ich
geheiratet
und da muss man sich dann schon
überlegen wieso ist davon danach zehn
jahren oft zu wenig da und was ist
schuld daran dass es zwischen den beiden
zu wenig klappt und da habe ich den
eindruck dass das so gar nicht an ihnen
selber liegt sondern an ihren
lebensumständen und an den erwartungen
die sie aneinander und anders leben
knüpfen sie selber sinha 40 jahre schon
heiratet ja sind sie glücklich
verheiratet ich fühle mich schon ein
bisschen angesprochen von dem bild nicht
schön also sagen wir jetzt hier ihren
mann noch einmal heiss politologe und
sie haben ja all gemeinsame söhne ich ja
ja ja was haben sie denn getan dass es
bei der kugelblitz uns nicht gespalten
wurde ja wir haben einerseits sehr
ähnliche auffassungen von den wirklich
wichtigen dingen im leben und ich habe
sicher bei meinem mann dinge gefunden
die ich selber nicht zur habe und nicht
zu können und umgekehrt wird auch so
gewesen sein also wir sind einander sehr
sympathisch
und haben immer gut miteinander
auskommen können was nicht heißt dass
wir nicht doch täglich darüber streiten
wer wo das licht nicht abgedreht hat das
gas nicht abgedreht hat eine zahnpasta
da bin ich zu gemacht hat also das ist
eigentlich immer mein mann der das alles
nicht macht und angreife deswegen nicht
um ihn stören weder andere dinge also
wir haben sicher unser quäntchen streit
jeden tag aber nie über wichtige dinge
und jetzt haben sie gesagt einer der
hauptgründe warum paare sich trennen
warum es zur scheidung kommt ist dass
die zu viel arbeiten
ein anderer grund den sie wieder
erwähnen ist das zweite kind
ja ja ja ja also da wären wir ja auch
das gegenbeispiel weil wir haben immer
beide viel gearbeitet zum beispiel und
haben zwei kinder aber für uns war eben
immer völlig klar dass uns unsere
jeweilige arbeit wichtig ist und dass
die für jeden einmal priorität rat wenn
mein mann auf dienstreise war war auf
dienstreise habe ich nicht gesagt
könntest du nicht zum elternsprechtag
gehen warum bist du auf dienst 30 und
bin ich verhandlung hatte dann hat die
verhandlung dann musste ich in der früh
weg stürzen
und er hat den kindern das frühstück
gemacht also das war für uns immer
vollkommen klar dass unsere berufe und
da keine wahl lassen und wir haben uns
das nicht gegenseitig zum vorwurf
gemacht und haben halt uns bemüht die
hilfe die wir gebraucht haben haben wir
zum teil in der familie gefunden vor
allem bei meiner schwiegermutter und zum
teil haben wir es halt zugekauft
indem ich wie ich jung war ungefähr das
was ich nicht verdient habe brutal für
eine kinderfrau gezahlt habe mit
nebenkosten und sozialversicherung bei
uns klar war es wird nicht ewig dauern
die kinder brauchen nicht ewig betreuung
körper berufstätig ist man bis zur
pensionierung also das heißt wenn ich
ihnen zuhöre als scheidungsanwältin und
als lange verheiratete frau würden sie
jungen paar
die heiraten wollen raten beide sollen
berufstätig seien beide sollen sich um
die kinder kümmern möglichst viel
gleichstellung sie sagen auch gemeinsame
konten sind ungefähr so hygienisch die
geteilte zahnbürsten das habe ich von
einer lieben freundin die ärztin jetzt
nicht jene ich sehe hier eine argumenten
geführt habe ich gehe im jahr das sind
ja weil doch jeder sein eigenes geld
selbst verwalten sollte ja natürlich
sollte man dann auch gemeinsam das leben
gestalten und jeder zahlt was er kann
und was er hat aber dass der andere auf
meinem konto umrührt und dort abhebt
also das tut man nicht nicht es ist auch
wenn wir gegenseitig mal uns mit
bargeldbeträgen aushelfen also keiner
greift in die brieftasche des anderen
und sagte ich habe kein geld ich brauche
ein taxi hast du zehn euro für mich dann
aber ideal der liebe die kugeln das
romantische bilder ist dass die
romantische verblödung dass man dann am
anfang denkt wir möchten doch alles
teilen das spielt doch alles gar keine
rolle mehr wie ein geld ist dein geld
und so weiter ist es traurig um das
nicht kümmern und
er wird es immer gut mit mir meinen und
ich kann mich ganz darauf verlassen dass
wenn ich nur kuchen backe und abends ein
gutes abendessen mache dann wird nämlich
noch wertschätzen wenn ich 70 bin und am
stock gehen so ist es halt leider nicht
warum nicht ihre erfahrung
also gilt immer noch goethes faust nicht
ein flinker jung hat andere wer jetzt
noch luft genug oder so ähnlich also
männer können sich leichter befreien von
den fässern einer ehe diese nicht mehr
als bereicherung sondern als fässer
verbinden und die frauen sind heute an
geschmierten wobei es auch viele frauen
gibt die gehen und man sagt heute gehen
eigentlich viele scheidungen sondern
frauen aus ja das gibt es natürlich gibt
es natürlich ja aber eigentlich wenn
überhaupt
wie gesagt also dieser ökonomische
einbruch macht es frauen ungleich
schwerer sich scheiden zu lassen
wenn frauen sich scheiden lassen wollen
dann haben sie in der er einen
leidensdruck wo sie dann irgendwann
sagen ich will einfach nicht mehr
aber wie gesagt das war früher leichter
dass mir eine frau gesagt hat jetzt sind
die kinder aus dem gröbsten heraus und
jetzt bin ich draufgekommen dass es nur
einen gibt den ich immer bedienen muss
und den will ich jetzt auch nicht mehr
das war so früher eine häufige
motivation für frauen so um die 40
dass sie zu mir gekommen sind das ist
jetzt ohnedies schwerer geworden
bei männern ist es fast immer die sich
ihnen anbietende alternative also selten
lässt sich ein mann scheiden weil er von
der frau und den kindern einfach genug
gehabt dass sie nicht eine andere
partnerin also das heißt sie können
sagen die frau sucht auf die
selbstständigkeit die freiheit
nicht bedienen müssen und der mann ihrer
erfahrung nach hat eine affäre also fast
alle scheidungen die von männern
ausgehen
auch dort wo einnahmen ich habe ja auch
männliche gehen und es ist sehr
interessant dass mehr männer dann oft
erzählen was ihnen in der ehe schon
jahrelang nicht mehr gepasst hat und wo
ich mir denke dass mir noch ganz gute
scheidungs gründe oft gewesen aber zu
mir kommen tun sie dann doch erst zu
wenn es schon eine andere interessenten
für sie gibt also es hat mir mal gesagt
männer denken in alternativen weiß ich
nicht aber es deckt sich mit meiner
erfahrung hängt vielleicht auch damit
zusammen dass sich männer nie so ganz
definieren müssen über die familie also
für die es die familien rahmen wo es
natürlich besser ist es klappt alles wie
es angehen ehemals es herrscht
sprachlosigkeit und unfreundlichkeit
aber männer sind doch meistens haben
zumindest den beruf als zweites
gleichwertiges standbein das heißt sie
bleiben vielleicht auch unter einem
missverhältnis in der ehe nicht so sehr
aber wenn sich dann auf tut eine andere
partnerin wobei das ja dann auch oft nur
illusion ist weil der alltag all denen
ja dann sowieso auch in einer neuen
beziehung ein das ist ja auch ein grund
warum ich nicht so sofort allen zur
scheidung rate aber es gibt ja gar keine
sozialwissenschaftliche forschung wie
zufrieden leute in ihrer zweiten
beziehung überhaupt sind weil dort muss
er dann auch schmutziges geschirr
gewaschen werden die schwiegermutter
besucht das kranke kaninchen zum
tierarzt gebracht
also ich verstehe dass sie nein wenn
entscheidung jetzt ein neues leben 31
mann ist eigentlich wieder mehr selbst
mit einem ganzen problemen
sie sagen manchmal auch sie müssen
eigentlich den emil der anderen menschen
trennen die jahren zu ihnen und bringen
den
gib uns mehr auf den schreibt genau wir
haben sie einen schönen beruf frau klar
ja ich habe einen schönen beruf weil ich
hier doch immer abends das gefühl habe
ich etwas nützliches getan
so auch als rechtsanwalt denke ich mir
wenn ich nur leute vertreten würde die
einen wand verbaut bestellt haben und
dann kommt der wand verbauen das zur
rose im ton und man muss jetzt da
wandlung oder preisnachlass geltend
machen
hätte ich vielleicht dieses gefühl der
nützlichkeit meiner tätigkeit nicht aber
das hängt vielleicht auch damit zusammen
dass ich es zu wenig mache also die
kollegen die sich auf
gewährleistungsansprüche spezialisiert
haben die würden jetzt vielleicht
aufschreien und sagen jemand der einen
rosé wand verbau hat und einen anderen
fall abtun wollte leidet ja auch so sie
tun auch ein andrang ja also das man
vielleicht ein bisschen betriebsblind
ich finde meine tätigkeit nützlich und
bin daher daher gerne aus und hinterher
mit meinem beruf zufrieden
nun gibt es ja in einer trennung nicht
nur zwei personen mann und frau oder
auch frauen frau und waren und man in
der schweiz in der schweiz gibt es ja
die edle noch nicht aber in
österreichischen region also gibt es
auch gleich gestellt werden ja wieder
trennen sondern es gibt es ja oft auch
kinder und über diese kinder spricht man
selten
es gibt einen dokumentarfilm der
schweizer filmemacherin jacqueline zünd
der ist auch nominiert für den schweizer
filmpreis er heißt where we belong und
der gibt entscheidungs kindern eine
stimme
für mich auf jeden fall ist schlimm wenn
man frau entscheidet sich mama und papa
denn manche mir so hallo bestehen die
blöd sofa gespinst mini ältere ich will
irgendwie entscheidet fische ich hasse
die hauptsache festung lange zusammen
kommen mehr
die fahrzeit uns halt unbedingt welle
und hat sehr manipuliert in der tat
immer so seit erreichte ernste und also
krank und gemüse wo unsere mutter
erzählt waage unsere mutter sie nicht
fähig für uns aufs wasser kann mir zu
mir
vielmehr wird alles besser auf dem motto
schlacht
[Musik]
zerstört eine das macht eine fertig wenn
denn bei die ältere teil besuchte
stacheln damen sind somit vier versteht
man das nicht und dem goldman auf das
unternehmen wieder ein die ältere teil
zerbricht in dem sinn wenn er vielleicht
damit um oka mehr verstoß nicht und es
schadet da sagen wir so ich hab doch
beide dinge wie so was ich jetzt da
eigentlich los
[Musik]
sprechen sie eigentlich mit den kindern
nein nein also kinder haben beim anwalt
ein beim scheidungsanwalt eltern nichts
verloren auch wenn manchmal frauen
kinder mitbringen dann habe ich ein paar
bilder bücher und stifte und so zeug das
dem vorzimmer erwarten können und nur
bei ganz kleinen kindern lasse ich die
mit rein und auch da finde ich es
unangenehm weil kinder nicht so dumm
sind wie ihre eltern manchmal glauben
und ich auch bei kleinen kindern fürchte
dass die verstehen wovon wir reden aber
ich spreche natürlich sehr viel über die
kinder so ich frag immer meine klienten
sofort was es an kindern gibt wie alt
welche schulen das auch ganz interessant
für mich also ich kann auf die art kann
ich mittlerweile auch den leuten schon
tipps geben in welche schule sie ihre
kinder geben schon um in welche nicht
weil ich da von anderen so viel höhere
[Gelächter]
aber natürlich stehen auch im zentrum
einer beratungen
steht natürlich die die probleme die
sich daraus ergeben dass man die kinder
hat nicht es gibt ja auch sehr viele
paare die haben ein schlechtes gewissen
den kindern gegenüber nein nein wir
haben überhaupt kein schlechtes gewissen
nein also was die leute den kindern
antun ohne das geringste schlechte
gewissen zu haben
verblüfft mich eigentlich immer wieder
muss man den schlächter ließen haben
kinder haben wir ja auch jetzt gehört
haben in der regel beide elternteile
gern wenn nicht ein ein besonderes
schicksal ist nicht hätten auch am
liebsten dass die eltern zusammenbleiben
also den kindern macht man mit der
scheidung selten eine freude
und wenn dann durch die scheidung auch
noch alles andere auseinanderbricht was
den kindern wichtig war halt ich das
eigentlich eine zumutung für die kinder
sagt du kannst nicht mehr in diese
schule gehen weil der vater zahlst nicht
mehr weil es eine teure privatschule ist
aber wegen der kinder zusammen bleiben
ist wahrscheinlich auch keine lösung
wenn man sich die ganze zeit streichen
wenn man die ganze zeit streite dieses
schiff für die kinder sicher schlimm
aber nur wenn sich das verhältnis der
eltern abkühlt aber man einander noch
halbwegs mit respekt begegnen kann denke
ich mir könnte man schon noch ein
weilchen so aus haben bis die kinder ein
alter haben wo sie selber ein eigenleben
haben wo es ihnen dann nicht mehr so
wichtig ist klar das ist etwas das
interessiert mich sehr an ihnen das ja
einerseits eine feministin sind ja sagen
sie sind eine kaum thema und so erleben
sie überhaupt nicht aber gerade als
feministin mir fand am texte ein wie zb
die nora von ipsen ja schöne
theaterstück nora oder ein puppenhaus
und diese nora ist eine mutter von
kindern sie verlässt diese familie oder
wie die familie verlassen und der mann
sagt immer wieder du bist mein singvogel
du bist ja ein kanarienvogel und sie
fühlt sich auch wie in einem
gesperrt das ist ja die situation auch
von vielen frauen in der geschichte
immer wieder lesen dass sie zwar schon
gerne bei den kindern bleiben würden
aber sie möchten sich auch befreien und
gerade dieser befreiungsschlag ja den
können sie auch nachvollziehbar da ist
ihr seid nora schon viel geschehen und
die frau dem käfig des mannes sitzt also
die tut es hier dann heutzutage wenn
dann freiwillig nicht ist das ja schon
nah so die meisten frauen erlernen einen
beruf und heiraten also in der regel
heiraten pias also leute die ein
leichtes sind ja ähnliche auf der
arbeitskollegen studienkollegen jemand
den man vom studium kennt nicht oft hat
die frau den qualifizierten abschluss
und die falle schnappt daneben insoferne
zu als durch das kinderkriegen sie
zurück gepumpt wird in die steinzeit
nicht dass das ist der knackpunkt nicht
dass es nicht gelingt diese
gleichwertigkeit und gleichberechtigung
über die kleinkinder phase der
gemeinsamen kinder hinüber zu retten
wechseln wir mal die seite haben wir
über die scheidung gesprochen über
trennung was spricht denn eigentlich für
die ehe oder man könnte auch mal wieder
max frisch hervor nehmen fragebogen von
max frisch zu jeder lautet frage 8 in
fragebogen zwei hätten sie von sich aus
frau klar die ihr hier erfunden
na ja möglicherweise doch ja
möglicherweise doch das hängt vielleicht
bei mir auch damit leben zusammen
da sich als einzelkind relativ alter
eltern schon immer so ein gewisses
gefühl der einsamkeit und vereinzelung
hatte
und ich habe sie auch schon neben kurz
angedeutet in der schule habe ich mich
nicht so wohl gefühlt unter den kindern
von russlandfeldzug teilnehmern bei den
sozialistischen studenten habe ich mich
nicht so heimelig gefüllt werden anti
amerika demos die wiener jüdische
gemeinde ist untergegangen und im
jüdischen religionsunterricht wo ich
teilgenommen habe
kinder deren eltern nicht in österreich
aufgewachsen sind und die zum teil viel
religiöser wahn als man eigentlich gar
nicht religiöses elternhaus dort habe
ich mich eigentlich auch sehr
außenseiter mäßig gefüllt und mit meinem
land habe ich mich gleich so gefühlt und
das war für mich schon sehr wichtig
einen menschen zu haben zudem ich gehöre
und der zu mir gehört und ich finde das
ganz viel besser als allein durchs leben
gehen also also ist für mich alternative
los wenn man das glück hat jemanden zu
finden mit dem man so das gefühl hat man
durch dick und dünn
das ist auch das ja muss man deswegen
heiraten warum braucht es nicht
ich frage ja nur warum braucht es
eigentlich noch die ehe ich habe schon
gesagt wir diskutieren der schweiz für
alle also man überlegte und dieses
rechtsinstitut ausdehnen soll
man könnte aber sagen um die
diskriminierung zum beispiel von
gleichgeschlechtlichen paaren ab
zuschauer könnte man auch gleich die ehe
für alle abschaffen dann wäre man ja in
sachen toleranz dann wären alle gleich
das hat natürlich dann wiederum einen
rechtlichen rahmen
wenn nicht sollten aus der ehe werden
doch auch rechtsansprüche abgeleitet die
für eine familie mit kindern schon ganz
nützlich sind nicht also ich hab
ehemalige konzipierten von mir die haben
mittlerweile das dritte kind also sie
haben sich selbstständig gemacht und
weiß nicht vielleicht haben sie in der
zwischenzeit geheiratet
aber da habe ich mir schon den mund
fusselig geredet wie sie noch bei uns
gearbeitet haben gesagt wenn einem von
euch was passiert und das kann man nicht
ausschließen
die halbwaisen pensionsansprüche bei so
jungen leuten bei euch sind ganz niedrig
und eine witwen oder witwer punktion
gibt es nicht weil er nicht verheiratet
zeit das ist eigentlich unverantwortlich
aber man könnte ja auch einen vertrag
einfach machen aber nicht zulasten
entschuldigen der öffentlichen systeme
also dass man vertrag macht wird er bald
jemand machen das mache ich mit der
hausbesorgerin auch wenn sie mir leid
tut dass sie eine punktion nach mehr
bekommt also dass das geht ja wohl nicht
dass jeder jedem pensionsansprüche
überträgt also dafür muss es ja schon
das system in das alle menschen ein
zahlen also da kann sie nicht der
beliebigkeit des einzelnen überlegen
wenn er daraus bedenken will also das
habe ich ja immer weil in österreich ist
natürlich ein gewisser nachteil kann man
sicher anders machen
bei uns hängt da wie zudem
pensionsanspruch am unterhalt und
natürlich habe ich immer männer die
sagen natürlich kann meine frau ruhig
die portion kriegen aber unterhalt
zahlen will ich hier nicht also dass und
solang man verheiratet ist hat man
zumindest diesen anspruch auf
hinterbliebenenpension nicht nach der
scheidung gibt es die pension eben nur
wenn zu unterhalt gezahlt wurde nicht
wie gesagt das ist ein system wo man
nachdenken könnte ob man nicht
vielleicht lieber so wie in deutschland
in pension splitting will für
verheiratete aber das ist eben auch für
verheirate vielleicht denke ich so
utopisch aber ich würde sie gerne da
noch ein bisschen kitzeln
noch einmal nehmen ist gäbe die ehe
nicht mehr
es gebe vielleicht die kirchliche
weiterhin religionsgemeinschaften wir
sind die paare segnen und unter den
segen gottes stellen aber das recht
würde sich zurückziehen und sagen das
sind einfach nur privatrechtliche
verträge die wir schließen wenn sie
jemanden heiraten können sie das
gemeinsam tun und einen entsprechenden
vertrag aushandeln
warum genau haben die diese idee dass
diese form von lebensgemeinschaft noch
geschützt werden muss vom staat
zusätzlich ja so natürlich hat der
begriff des staates einen gewissen
wandel
während früher die staatliche autorität
war haben wir doch jetzt fast überall
staatsformen die dem schwächeren schutz
bieten
und wenn jeder sich seinen ehevertrag
selber aus handelt möchte ich eigentlich
nicht wissen was da drinsteht von sexual
freiheit für den mann und verzicht auf
unterhaltsansprüche durch die frau und
da kommt dann eben die romantische
verblödung dass es sicher genug frauen
gibt die jeden blödsinn unterschreiben
würden weil sie sich nicht vorstellen
können dass es jeder zukäme und da ist
es schon besser wenn der rahmen dieses
vertrages will die sie ein vertrag sie
ein vertrag ist nur halt vom gesetz
vorgegeben wozu dieser vertrag
verpflichtet also verpflichtet zum
gemeinsamen wohnen zur treue zum
beistand und zur anständigen begegnung
nicht dass das ist der rahmen in dem das
gesetz vorgibt halte ich gar nichts
davon dass sie das ich selber aushandelt
ist es mir auch lieber es gibt in der
arbeitswelt kollektivverträge
als jeder unternehmer bestimmt selber
den lohn und den urlaubsanspruch der
arbeiteten
ich habe diese frage nur so gestellt
weil es eine diskussion gibt in der
philosophie zum beispiel die gender
wissenschaftlerin sophie la mezquita
oder die philosophin elisabeth break die
arbeiten zu diesen themen und fordern
diese abschaffung der ehe damit zum
beispiel auch pauli amouröse paare nicht
diskriminiert werden dass alle formen
von lebensgemeinschaften gleichgestellt
sind
aber ich höre jetzt dass man sich in der
liebe ein stück weit immer ja auch
verletzlich macht man kriegt eben
gemeinsam kinder man nirgends und
hässlich und deswegen braucht es diese
formen vom schutz nun ist es aber so
unsere gesellschaft wandelt sich und
viele menschen lassen sich scheiden
ich finde interessant wieviel noch
dieses spiel ein vielleicht haben sie
selber auch mal dieses spiel gespielt
spielen des lebens nein das würde in den
60er jahren schon entwickelt man immer
noch kaufen
im spiel des lebens kriegt man ein auto
man kriegt ein männlein und weiblein wir
haben der vollständigkeit halber auch
ein auto gemacht mit zwei männlein das
war aber natürlich so vorgesehen
wenn ein und weiblein und dann kriegt
man kinder maximal vier wie man sehen
kann wie man fährt durchs leben man wird
reich also man ergreift berufe manieren
reinigt man baut häuser und so weiter
scheidung ist in diesem spiel des lebens
nicht vorgesehen
aha im spiel des lebens heute frau klar
ist die scheidung bei vielen menschen ja
jeden wie vorgesehen
leider oder was würden sie dazu sagen ja
also es wird immer darauf hingewiesen
40 prozent aller ehen scheitern das sind
auch die zahlen in österreich die ich
immer höre aber das bedeutet eine
scheidung bedeutet auch immer
entscheiden es heiratet niemand weil er
sich scheiden lassen will und man sagt
so ja natürlich
kann eine ehe auch schief gehen da sagt
man so wie man in ein flugzeug einsteigt
und weiß es könnte auch abstürzen
aber man rechnet auch nicht damit steht
man es nicht ist natürlich der
flugzeugabsturz doch ein bisschen
weniger wahrscheinlich als verkleidung
ja trotzdem ist jedes mal eine kränkung
also diese vorstellung zu sagen und dann
ist halt unsere häuser sie es
gescheitert und jetzt sehen wir dass
beide ein und jetzt hüpfen wir zum
gericht und lassen uns scheiden und
bleiben beste freunde
das halte ich für ein ganz statistische
werbe maßnahme mit der man allen leuten
ein schlechtes gewissen machen will bei
denen es nicht so klappt
in wirklichkeit ist es natürlich die
kränkung dass man sich vom anderen nicht
mehr geliebt fühlt dass wenn man
jemanden gerne hat oder gern gehabt hat
und der marke nicht mehr das ist eine
kränkung das kann also doch kein mensch
wegleugnen vielleicht sieht man auch ein
eigenes scheitern
das kann das auch sehr tiefgreifend sein
weil man vielleicht etwas wiederholt was
man bei den eltern gesehen hat und immer
anders machen wollte
man hat die probleme mit der vermögens-
teilung und dem sinkenden lebensstandard
man hat die probleme mit den kindern die
die scheidung in der regel nicht wollen
also ich glaube es wir haben die
schwierigkeiten und negativen seiten der
scheidung werden zu ein bisschen
[Musik]
wegretuschiert und natürlich würde ich
hier schon sagen doch immer von
denjenigen die die scheidung wollen und
das sind halt eben die männer mit der
alternative die dann sagen tut ihr nix
an und zu 40 prozent aller ehen
scheitern und was soll das aber
ich glaube das ist eine verleugnung
wirkliches kränkung potenzial und
welcher finanzielle einbruch mit einer
scheidung verbunden ist also man sollte
das nicht bagatellisieren
zum schluss frau klar ärgern sie
manchmal ihre klientinnen gehen die
ihnen manchmal auch auf den wecker ich
meine paare die sich streiten dass es
manchmal ja auch ein bisschen unangenehm
[Musik]
also die leute kommen hier zu mir weil
sie sich streiten also wenn ich mich
darüber ärgern wollte musste ich eben
doch gewährleistungsansprüche gegen
möbelhersteller mehr vertreten nicht
letztlich sagte anwalt ein dienstleister
kann sich die klienten nicht wirklich so
aussuchen und im gegenteil finde ich ist
es ja schon so dass meistens anwälte und
klienten irgendwie zusammenpassen und
sich auch gegenseitig ein bisschen
sympathisch sind und daher glaube ich
habe ich also diesbezüglich auch weniger
arbeitslos leute in anderen berufen
vielen dank für dieses gespräch ich
hoffe ich habe sie nicht geärgert
viele herren spielen ja nächste woche
spricht ich boss hat mit den
bekanntesten forensischen psychiater der
schweiz nämlich mit frank urbaniok über
sein neues buch das in diesen tagen
erscheint und über das gefährliche tier
in uns und jetzt gleich folgende einer
der größten stimmen unserer zeit auf
ihren neuen wegen die stars organistin
barbara hannigan dirigiert ihre erste
oper und besetzt diese mit jungen
unbekannten stimmen
lassen sie sich verführen von gesang
bleiben sie gesund bis bald
[Musik]